les avions thunder birdie les blue
angels de la marine américaine ont percé
le ciel de washington un geste pour
rendre hommage aux travailleurs qui
combattent chaque jour la pandémie aux
etats unis la moitié des états
s'apprêtent à lancer leur déconfinement
mais pas tous en même temps ni de la
même façon
pour exane on trouve des restaurants de
même que des magasins et des
bibliothèques
à condition qu'il ne fonctionne qu'au
quart de leurs capacités cette
restauratrice de houston explique avoir
pris toutes les précautions nécessaires
nous avons décidé d'installer des paroi
en plexiglas autour du bar tous nos
clients et nos employés vont devoir
porter les masques et des gants
d'autres états mais tiennent encore de
sévères restrictions
le gouverneur de l'état de new york dit
comprendre les opposants au confinement
mais qu'il est encore nécessaire jusqu'à
la mi mai
vous ne pouvez pas rester tout le temps
à l'intérieur
les gens vont sortir et c'est super mais
respectez la distanciation sociale et
porter un masque
bouffée d'air frais en europe après un
mois et demi de confinement des milliers
d'espagnols ont pu sortir pour une
promenade ou même faire du sport le port
du masque sera obligatoire dans les
transports publics
en france on appliquera un déconfinement
progresser par régions dès le 11 mai
mais ce n'est pas la fin de l'état
d'urgence est dit que les autorités le
projet de loi présenté ce matin en
conseil des ministres entend proroger
l'état d'urgence sanitaire pour deux
mois jusqu'au 24 juillet d'ici là les
signes de solidarité se manifeste d'un
bout à l'autre de la planète comme la
tour eiffel illuminée ici gabriel pro
radio canada montréal